CIA has multiple ways of recruiting
there is Word of Mouth for sure there's
word of mouth and that's for a very deep
cover kind of Niche area because there
you you're looking for people with
established credibility and in some
special field so you it's not easy to
find business people who are actually
running successful businesses and then
you want to turn them into spies that's
that's a hard thing to do so you look
for word of mouth and then you have
things like the government World anybody
trying to move from one government job
to another government job that can be
automated that's easy and then you've
got the whole world of college
recruiting where you have either
somebody who's a recruiter on campus or
somebody who's a regional recruiter that
visits multiple campuses and you will
literally find CIA you know cheesy stall
with a sign at almost every college
recruiting event for big colleges
[Music]
foreign